Ever since the pioneering work of
Turing and his contemporaries, such as
Alonzo Church and Kurt Gödel, mathematic
logicians have studied the power of
computation and connecting it to prove
ability, as well as giving us new
insights on the nature of information,
even philosophy and economics.
Computability has a downside,
just because we can solve a problem on
a Turing machine, doesn't mean
that we can solve it quickly.
What good is having
a computer solve a problem,
if our sun explodes before
we get to the answer?
So for now we'll leave the study of
computable functions and languages, and
move to computational complexity.
Trying to understand the power
of efficient computation.
And learning about the famous
P verses NP question.